estamos en el museo nacional de
antropología en mexico mirando a lo que
quizás sea su objeto más famoso el
calendario azteca también conocido como
la piedra del sol se ha convertido en el
emblema de la cultura mexicana tiene una
forma circular como si fuera un sol que
emana rayos pero si lo miramos de cerca
en realidad nos vamos a dar cuenta que
se trata de un objeto increíblemente
sofisticado esta piedra originalmente
estaba pintada y lo cual pues nos habría
ayudado mucho a distinguir los motivos
que estamos viendo no estaba empotrada
en la pared más bien estaba colocada de
manera horizontal sobre el suelo y no
estaba terminada vamos a comenzar por el
centro aquí sería una cara medio tétrica
con los ojos muy sumidos y una boca
ancha a cada uno de sus lados cuelgan lo
que parecieran ser ornamentos para las
orejas lleva orejeras y dentro de esa
boca abierta hay una lengua que
sobresale esa lengua en realidad es un
cuchillo de sacrificios antropomorfo las
orejeras serán adornos que utilizaban la
élite
si miramos a los lados encontraremos que
tiene garras y esas garras están
sosteniendo algo que probablemente son
corazones humanos ha habido varias
interpretaciones sobre quién era en
realidad este individuo la mayoría de
las personas lo identifican con el dios
del sol donativo que es la palabra
náhuatl para el dios del sol
nagua que es la lengua que hablaban los
aztecas quienes pertenecían a un grupo
étnico llamado nahuas lo que se registra
aquí en esta imagen en el centro es más
lo que se registra en todo el disco en
general es como los aztecas visualizaban
el origen del cosmos la piedra se
refiere a uno de los principales mitos
aztecas la creación de las diferentes
épocas o como ellos mismos las llaman ni
los soles lo que estamos viendo aquí es
un registro una historia cataclísmica de
épocas anteriores y también la época
actual la época actual pues es
considerada como como el quinto sol sin
embargo el nombre del quinto sol la
quinta era es cuatro movimiento de hecho
eso es lo que vemos con los cuatro
rectángulos que rodean las figuras
y ese signo que se forma es el símbolo
de ollin que en agua que significa
movimiento también vemos esos cuatro
puntos que rodean la figura central que
nos dan el nombre de nahui ollin cuatro
movimiento que es el título del quinto
sol o la quinta época que estamos
viviendo en nuestros momentos dentro de
esos rectángulos que significan nahui
ollin cuatro movimiento vemos los
nombres de los cuatro soles anteriores
a ver si partimos de la parte superior
derecha y le damos vuelta conforme al
contrario de las manecillas del reloj
las cuatro eras son cuatro jaguar cuatro
viento cuatro tlaloc y cuatro
chalchiuhtlicue la primera era se acaba
con los jaguares todo es devorado por
los jaguares la segunda era se termina
con fuertes vientos la tercera era se
acaba con con esta lluvia de fuego y
bueno pues la cuarta era se acaba con
inundaciones de agua el quinto sol
profetiza que este mundo actual en el
que vivimos va a terminar con terremotos
la ciudad donde estamos y de dónde
proviene la piedra la capital azteca
está rodeada de volcanes y de una línea
de falla los terremotos han sido
espantosos y lo que esta piedra está
profetizando es cómo va a terminar
nuestro mundo actual con esa cara en el
centro hay una idea clara de sacrificio
existe dentro de la mitología azteca el
concepto de que ésta era en la cual
estamos viviendo ha sido formada por dos
dioses que se ponen de acuerdo para
sacrificarse ellos mismos se realizan la
creación del sol gracias al sacrificio
que hacen los dioses pero en un
principio el sol era estático por eso es
que se requiere del sacrificio de otro
dios para poner al sol en movimiento
debido a que los dioses han muerto de
manera voluntaria nosotros debemos
alimentarlos con ofrendas sacrificios de
animales o perforaciones de nuestro
propio cuerpo ofrendando nuestra sangre
o sacrificios humanos aquí tenemos 20
glifos o símbolos los 20 días del
calendario azteca fuera de esta franja
de fechas calendar y cas
vemos los rayos del sol que irradia
hacia el exterior donde los más grandes
señalan los cuatro puntos cardinales
norte sur este y oeste su universo se
dividía en cuatro cuadrantes asociados
con estos cuatro puntos cardinales
tenochtitlán la ciudad capital del
imperio azteca estaba dividida también
en cuatro replicando ese diagrama
cosmológico si nos fijamos bien en la
banda exterior vamos a encontrar un par
de serpientes cuyas cabezas se juntan en
la parte interior central y de estas
cabezas surgen dos caras estas estas
serpientes se llaman serpientes de fuego
o chuck o ati están asociadas con el
tiempo con el calendario solar y en
algunas fuentes aparecen como portadoras
del sol a través del cielo es decir
ellas finalmente pues hacen que el
tiempo transcurra en cuanto a la forma
de fechar este monumento hay un par de
otros glifos aquí que me gustaría
señalar junto a la fecha 4 viento si
vamos hacia la izquierda nos encontramos
con la insignia real de montes una
segundo
pues nos hace fechar este monumento
durante el reinado de de este monarca
azteca al otro lado de la insignia de
monte zona segundo justo al lado de esa
cabeza de jaguar que marca la fecha 4
jaguar vemos un cuchillo de pedernal uno
de los cuchillos de sacrificio
junto a él vemos un punto sólo esto se
lee como la fecha 1 pedernal algunas
personas asocian esa fecha en particular
con el comienzo de la era del quinto sol
lo que tenemos aquí es un sentido de la
estructura y el orden del universo de
los aztecas es un objeto que es muy muy
conocido sin embargo la mayoría de las
personas no están conscientes de los
mensajes tan sofisticados que se
transmiten en el calendario azteca
bueno